tennis player john mcenroe is one of the
sport's greatest players winning 77
singles titles and seven grand slams
during his career but he's also
remembered for his antics on the court
and memorable phrases like you cannot be
serious
mcenroe is sharing some thoughts on that
in a new documentary
all right just keep yourself under
control
just go play
and then boom everything would go out
the window
don't do that
do not do that
what are you a stupid
[ __ ]
no no the call came before the ball was
played he never even called me well no
no he never said anything
planet please did i have the referee
please no no no i have the referee
i'd like to have a referee
i was crazed
nervous energy flying all over the place
intensity
anger
mentally i became
really good at being able to
compartmentalize to a degree
if you watch other players in most
sports
if they go off the rails
it's very difficult to pull it back in
that was one of the things
it is a really compelling watch the
documentary is called mcenroe and it
will air on showtime which like cbs is
the division of paramount global john
mcenroe good morning good morning to you
thank you i'm impressed you all are you
claim to have watched it no we did
quizzes
documentary i love the last 10 minutes
to be honest with you i think it it
really solidifies who you are and talks
about love and as we said in the teas
vulnerability and all those thank you i
don't remember the last 10 minutes but
um
it's brutally honest and i i wonder you
know what the the documentary starts
with you saying i am
the greatest player of all time and i
remember well that was do you know when
i said it
because
1984 or five okay so it was a while ago
it was a while ago before these other
guys what i don't know federer nadal
djokovic these guys seem to have gone by
me but um
at that moment
today
do i believe today that i'm the greatest
player that ever lived was was was uh
at that particular moment in time yeah
it was quite a while ago i had a lot you
know my hair was a different color with
different times you know the end of wood
racket era but at that moment i thought
i'd taken the game to another level we
hear from you in the documentary about
your father and how his you know you
wanted to to please him but we hear
about his sort of controlling behavior
and wanting to make you a winner you
also say in the documentary i'm not an
empathetic person and that is my biggest
flaw i wonder if it's 63 years old you
think you are empathetic today uh six
kids later i'm better than i was i
wouldn't call that my strong suit uh
i sort of look at things fairly black
and white
although it ends up everything ends up
being sort of a gray area like when push
comes to shove i mean look at politics
right everyone's so one one side or the
other but it seemed like we'd be better
off somewhere in the middle and i think
in general i think that would be
better the way to lead life in that
manner yeah your wife uh patty says at
one point in the documentary that she
she married the super brat that your
reputation for outburst but she ended up
with the good dad uh you've been on this
stream well that was actually my
favorite line in the movie she said i
married a bad boy who turned into a good
man a good man yeah so that to me was
like you know it gives me goosebumps
even now i mean you know i got a second
chance which a lot of people can relate
to in in a marriage for example so uh
that allowed me i i say in the in the
documentary but it's also obviously true
that allowed me to sort of be me like
the person i wanted to be as a person
you know sort of it was more difficult
but i was younger the first time around
yeah
the other thing that's really
interesting is uh someone exactly dug up
uh i think your mom was the one who
showed uh someone your report card or
teacher review when you're in first
grade
and john was deemed too hard on himself
which suggests that you were always you
on the court there was a part of you
that would not accept anything less than
perfection and that that uh
unwillingness to allow yourself to just
screw up is what led to this bad boy
persona
um
maybe that's not an interesting theory
no no i think that uh you know
definitely i wish my parents were still
around because they were sort of
perfectionists they were great parents
uh i felt love uh in you know so that
that's not the issue there it's just uh
it never seemed like it was enough you
always had to do more and i think that
some point that becomes uh a detriment
as opposed to something that's positive
at first you know you strive to succeed
and you need to be pushed in a way i
mean living in the city there's an
energy in new york city you know why are
you turning to the person you were you
know there's you know i haven't spoken
to zigman freud's relatives lately you
know i've been fortunate i haven't seen
too many psychologists or psychologists
recently
but the bottom line is that you sort of
like how did he become the person he did
when he started yelling at these umpires
and i don't think there's any simple
answer yeah part of it obviously was my
parents uh you know they pushed me and
the fact that they
my dad was you know number two out of
500 people in law school my mom said why
aren't you number one
so
it always felt like you had to keep you
know going and so i was like one
wimbledon enough two three you know yeah
now i wish it had better i'd listen to
it more because these other guys have so
many more i'm like left you know i'm
like where what happened i have one
quick question about the us open since
you're gonna be covering it right i know
so uh
nicholas curios hot head now what do you
think of him uh you know i love nick uh
he's a great kid uh he could win the
whole thing if he kept his head together
that's the bottom line he's he moves the
needle for us but you often won the
whole thing and you didn't keep your
head together so you're kind of well
then you're not right we're going to go
to black they're going to take us off i
want to tell people the title it's
called mcenroe you cannot be serious
we're out of time are you kidding me
i'm out of here i'm out of here all
right we'll be right back